ملياردير بالجيتس قدم للطلاب في حفل
التخرج بجامعه شمال اريزونا مجموعه من
النصائح كان يتمنى لو قدمت له يوم تخرجه
الذي لم يحصل عليه ابدا جيت لم ينهي
دراسته الجامعيه قط فقد انسحب من جامعه
بعد ثلاثه فصول دراسيه ليبدا تاسيس شركه
مايكروسوفت نتعرف الان على هذه النصائح مع
الزميل على سرحان علاء
نعم
اليكم هذه النصائح الخمس التي قدمها
الملياردير بيل جيتس للخريجين الجدد ليكون
لهم اكبر تاثير على العالم مستقبلا اولى
هذه النصائح حياتك ليست مسرحيه من فصل
واحد فمن المحتمل ان تواجه الكثير من
الضغوط لاتخاذ القرارات الصحيحه بشان
حياتك المهنيه لكن لا تقلق هذه القرارات
ليست دائمه لانه من الجيد اعاده تقييم
واهدافك يقول لان تكون ابدا ذكيا جدا بحيث
لا تخطئ فالخطوه الاولى لتعلم شيء جديد هي
الميل الى ما لا تعرفه بدلا من التركيز
على ما تعرفه ونصح بالبحث عن اشخاص اذكياء
لتتعلم منهم ولا تخف من طلب المساعده منا
النصائح ايضا الجذاب للعمل الذي يحل مشكله
شجع الطلاب على اغتنام الفرص لمساعده
الاخرين قائلا عندما تقضي ايامك في القيام
بشيء يحل مشكله كبيره فانه يشجعك على
القيام بافضل اعمالك ايضا لا تقلق من شان
قوه الصداقه نصح جيتس الخريجين الجدد
بمواصله علاقاتهم الاجتماعيه في الكليه
فالاشخاص الذين جلست بجوارهم في المحاضرات
ليسوا مجرد زملاء في الفصل هم شبكتك وافضل
مصادر الدعم والمعلومات
والماشوره اخيرا انت لست متهربا اذا سمحت
لنفسك ببعض التراخي يمكن ان يؤدي العمل
الجاد الى زياده الاجور او الصعود في سلم
الشركات لكن لا يجب ان تفعل ذلك على حساب
حياتك فهناك ما هو اكثر في الحياه من
العمل لمتابعه المزيد من والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات